this song visiting hours i don't know
much about this guy who was your friend
mentor oh michael yeah who is this guy
to you well so he started off being my
australian promoter but i became close
to him pretty much instantly because he
gave my manager his first job uh so i
met him in like 2011 and you know he's a
promoter so you know you know promoting
he's a super fun guy super personal big
personality yeah big big personality and
i did tours with with him and always had
fun my biggest show that i did in like
2015 and i did wembley stadium and i had
a after party with seven of my best
friends and michael like and it would be
like us
22 year olds and michael who was
probably like 57 at the time or
something like that and you know we both
had our career highs together we both
together sold the most tickets that had
ever been sold in australia he on the
day that they announced it right it's
australian summer and he got an ice
sculpture of me made to announce that
we'd sold a million tickets and invited
all the press and i think i'd been out
the night before
you know uh it was sleeping in and the
ice sculpture basically just melted a
bit
before i turned up but um yeah man he's
like just a fantastic bloke just a
fantastic bloke and he um sadly passed
away in march
was it a sudden thing like he was he
sick for a long time or did he just
suddenly die and you never got to say
goodbye to him yeah yeah it was
literally that it was and i and the way
that i've been talking about it in in
interviews is like you know my
grandparents have died and i feel like
when you're at school everyone's
grandparents are dying so you sort of
accept that that's going to happen at
some point and my grandmother got very
sick in 2016 and
it was like an eight-month process of
her passing away and we i've got to move
back home and spend loads of time with
her and have loads of conversations she
told me about her childhood and you know
we had
i and by the time she passed away like
it was really sad but everyone had kind
of made peace with it whereas with
michael i got a call at three o'clock in
the morning from his son
just saying
and i knew i knew as soon as i got the
call um
yeah i basically woke up um my my it was
actually to my wife's phone she she
nudged me i woke up and she said matt is
calling uh and i i just i just instantly
knew and um yeah it was
like i've never i've never had anything
that that heavy happen and um
uh i managed to get out to australia for
his memorial but it was in quarantine
where i finished
this song and um
yeah man like grief's just uh it's a
heavy heavy thing that i just hadn't
experienced and being sort of locked in
a
house waiting
to go to this thing to grieve with his
family and kind of figuring out
what the hell was going on and it's good
i think i think the best thing
about being in that house was having my
daughter she was like six months and
also kids don't know what the hell is
going on so she's like but i'm happy so
then you suddenly have to
be
be happy yeah be happy i don't know
what's worse no goodbye or i don't want
the longer bye i think i'll be too sad i
don't i couldn't bear to say goodbye to
everyone i mean that's this that's what
this song is about like i'm i've
i've accepted that he's not coming back
but all i want is five more minutes
that's what the song's about it's about
having a visiting house where you go in
and you go hey man i'm gonna see you in
10 20 30 40 50 60 years whatever what
whatever it is i will see you but before
i go
this is what
this is what's going on